allerdings sind diese spinnen quasi
direkt von anfang an tumor- oder ist
drin aber die anderen realisieren ich
erst wenn ich was kaputt machen hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft fakes die folge
kam nicht gestern sondern kommen heute
am mittwoch weil ich das gestern nacht
noch im urlaub war und das spiel zu
hause war und dann habe ich das ganze
nicht mehr so richtig hingekriegt das
zur menschlichen seite hochzuladen aber
ich hoffe das ist euch trotzdem gefällt
auch wenn es heute kommt vorweg erst mal
irgendwann in diesem video wird wieder
ein kleiner black screen sein wo ihr ein
geräusch vorgespielt bekommt und ihr
könnt mir dann und in die kommentare
schreiben
welches geräusch das denn mit etwas
glück werdet ihr in der nächsten mai
kräftig folge am nächsten dienstag
erwähnt weil dann hoffe ich dass ich bis
zum berg schafft werden und das auch
noch mal vorher gesagt dass sie mir
fällt zugesendet werden können an
konkreter gmail.com aber bitte nur fake
sie ihr noch nicht irgendwo anders
gesehen habt in welchen anderen videos
und irgendwie sonstwas weil diese serie
besteht quasi nur aus euren text und da
macht es keinen sinn werden gesagt okay
komme ich habe ein video geschaut gerade
diesen weg gesehen den sei nicht immer
einfach zu und das macht dann keinen
sinn weil ich sehe da wirklich nur auf
ex und nehme nur die funktionieren und
die auch cool sind und die nicht schon
irgendwo anders vorgekommen sind und
deswegen hoffe ich dass ihr da
verständnis für mich habt und
verständnis für die leute die wir das zu
senden dass ihr da das kapiert und ihr
packt da schon zwar wurde mit der erste
weg von razzie also wahrscheinlich dass
minecraft zugesendet und zwar es ist ein
sehr sehr cool effect ich habe in der
letzten folge gesagt das ist ein wenig
blöd ist dass man keine halb stufen
blöcke harfst blogs übereinander setzen
kann wenn die verschieden sind
darum geht es auch nicht sondern es geht
um etwas anderes aber es hat trotz mit
diesem habe half step blogs zu tun und
zwar zieht die hier schon etwas
eingeblendeten zwar gehst dann euren
in-game nahm bei mir ist es konkreter
dann minecraft doppelpunkte dann können
wir entweder boden unterstrich sap oder
staunen unterstrich slap also es gibt ja
einmal wurden und stones labs eingeben 1
und dann acht also dann bekomme ich
beispielsweise eine eichenholz stufe und
die habe ich auch noch einige neue
studie zeigt euch was unterscheidet die
beiden na ja wenn ich ihn auf den boden
setzte das war mein handy also wenn ich
dir auf dem boden setzte dann geht die
so nach oben
und diese ist da unten allerdings kann
ich wenn ich jetzt hier eine obere drauf
mache sind die nicht beieinander das
scheint wohl echt einfach note zu geben
wenn das so geht
und auch wenn ich zum beispiel hier bei
der hier beim baumaterial wenn
beispielsweise eine treppenstufe nehme
kann ich die da auch nicht darauf setzen
allerdings wenn man direkt stufen haben
will die einfach so nach oben gehen
natürlich kann auch hier so eine stufe
anbringen dem ich einfach auf die obere
seite des blockes cook oder hier auf die
untere seite des blockes aber hiermit
kann nicht quasi auch wenn ich auf die
untere seite des blockes gucke die stufe
ist immer oben und somit kann man sich
quasi einen wurden slepzowa in stores
abgeben der immer auf der oberen seite
ist hey warum ist ein black screen ja
wir sind beim gaben ist vor dem geräusch
angelangt und zwar wurde das letzte game
ist voller geräusche erraten von backes
16 oder bis 16 uhr sowie bagger nur mit
es am ende egal und jedenfalls war zum
taschentuch aus einer box gezögert er
richtig erraten
das heißt wenn ich das jetzt gerade hört
also wenn ich gleich das geheimnisvolle
geräusche für diese folge gehört habe
schreibt das direkt in die kommentare
weil dann ist eure chance größer
beziehen sie nicht größer diesmal größer
bin ich ganz oft rein schreibt aber ihr
könnt ihr dann vielleicht in der
nächsten folge minecraft fact erwähnt
werden und zwar ist das keine toleranz
für diese folge dass hier
was habe ich gerade gemacht bzw solltet
ihr einen hier kennen weiter geht's der
nächste feld wurde mir zugesendet von
nico helmut kraft de
und zwar meint er wenn ich in einem
glashaus bin und vorher hier schon
monster gespannt habe also nicht das
gibt's bei monster mich irgendwie vorher
schon auf irgendeine art und weise
gesehen haben oder irgendwie durch
andere aspekte spawnen also wenn ich
hier quasi monsters vorne und zwar sei
es eine spinne salzen zombie krieg
skipper lasse ich mal aus weil ich nicht
will dass hier nicht doch durch
irgendwie irgendwas kaputt geht
fokussiert mich nur direkt die spinne
wenn ich dann quasi mich wieder ein game
und null bewegung also ihr seht das
schon hier ich habe so eine glashütte
gebaut
ich werde die tür gleich auch noch aus
glas bier nicht heraus bin und zwar und
nehme ich jetzt diese teile hier dann
sportlich eine spinne das geht aber
erstmal noch nicht welcher dafür ist man
das ganze auf einfach stellen muss
transport zum beispiel mal drei spiele
drei zombies und drei skelette ist
begebe ich mich hier rein macht die
firma weg und mache alles aus glas und
jetzt mache ich das ganze nicht die
teilen sondern ich mache mich in den
games 0 und ihr seht schon die spinnen
bewegen sich nach oben allerdings zombie
und skelette bewegen sich nicht hinten
sind auch relativ viele auch ich
vollidiot jetzt wollen wir auch dahin
die spinnen sind total aktiv wie sonst
was allerdings kombis und so den es
eigentlich relativ scheißegal die gucken
zwar so aber die werden mich quasi erst
nur angreifen wenn ich dann wirklich was
ausmacht also die rast letztlich übels
auswählen dann auch immer mal weg
bewegen und diese spinnen diese
nächtliche aggressiv die die fokussiere
mich direkt aber wenn ich quasi guckt
dieses klartext möchte ich hier mache
fokussiert mit jedes blatt erst und mich
dann noch ernst abbe land und da sie
mich jetzt fokussiert haben ist das
skelett jetzt auch richtig geil auf mich
aber es kam ich erst wieder ab wenn ich
hier quasi darauf schießt also nicht
diese sondern echtes kaputtmache
allerdings sind diese spinnen quasi
direkt von anfang an da ist einer drin
aber die anderen realisieren mich erst
wenn ich was kaputt mache dann kann dich
nico dritte effekt wurde mit zugesendet
von elias und zwar meine elias
eisengitter plus glasscheibe verbinden
sich pflasterstein mauer und bemoosten
pflasterstein mauer verbinden sich aber
zäune und ziegel netter ziegel zone
nicht und das ist nämlich eine sache die
ich mich schon sehr auf frage und das
ging jetzt in jeder minecraft folgen
letzten immer noch so das sind so sachen
die ich mir einfach
wünsche dass es verbessert wird es gibt
auch von anfang an von updates update
immer noch ein paar dinge die verbessert
werden aber das ist noch so sachen die
ich mir wünsche und ich diese effekt
serien kann ich mir das super festhalten
was quasi mojang mal besser machen
sollte und zwar beispielsweise ihr seht
es hier schon wenn ich die beiden nehme
jetzt hier soll eine hin und hier
verbinden sich direkt das gleiche auch
mit glas und dem zeugs also hier quasi
über hier so glas verbindet sich die
stars wenn ich allerdings normale zeile
und netter ziegel zäune habe kann ich da
zwischendurch laufen und das regt mich
einfach immens auf weil hier ist es zum
beispiel so dass dann einfach die hälfte
aus glas und die hälfte davon und jetzt
auch wieder so die hälfte ist davon und
die hälfte davon
deswegen könnte man hier quasi auch
machen dass der zaun einfach dann bis
hierhin geht also dass der sound ihr
seht es quasi denn sonst hier drin ist
so sind zwei blöcke verbindet das wetter
und quasi so steht steht er hier
und dieser zaun ist dann quasi so wie
hier das seien quasi so da ist
aber nein das ganze funktioniert ich das
funktioniert mit diesen mit allen
blöcken außer mit netter ziegeln oder
ziegel zäunen und holzsäulen danke die
hass letzte werk wurde mir zugesendet
von mystic falls und zwar kann man ja
normalerweise kein obsidian mit einer
eisen spitzhacke ab und deswegen habe
ich euch ganz normal vorbereitet wenn
ich ein obsidian ich bin im game roddick
vollidiot gamer und null game zu null
alles muss hier wieder schiefgeht diese
erfolge werkstatt ich bin gerade aus dem
urlaub zurück muss mich erstmal wieder
das ganze gewöhnen hier jedenfalls wenn
ich mir das ganze mit einer diamant
spitzhacke abbaue merkte ich schon nach
einer gewissen
dann hab ich den wenn ich das ganze
allerdings mit einer reisen spitzhacke
mache
ein blogger abbauen kann da etwas
anderes sind jedenfalls ist es so wenn
ich einen end einer energies mache
brauche ich dafür ja ich möchte hat man
mich regt es auf wenn da vier alles
kaputt gehe brauche ich dafür obsidian
um sie zu kräften das rezept könnt ihr
einfach selbst aussuchen wenn ihr in
eurem microsoft geht oder wenn ihr bei
minecraft geändert eingibt oder so
allerdings müssen sie dann eigentlich
sein da in diesem ändert es
hauptsächlich obsidian verbaut wird und
ihr seht schon die hälfte ist aus
obsidian es geht natürlich mit einem dia
mit einer diamant spitzhacke aber es
geht auch mit einer eisen spitzhacke und
das ist ein bisschen irreführend weil
wenn man quasi dann hat man verbaut ist
und man hat ein ganz normaler obsidian
blog kann man ihn nur mit diamant
abbauen und nicht mit leisen aber wenn
man in die er den obsidian login eine
ändert fest verarbeitet kann man es
trotz mit beiden abbauen das ist auf
jeden fall etwas was der name von ihm
schon sagte zwar mystic falls das ist
echt mystisch aber ich würde sagen das
war es auch schon wieder mit den
heutigen minecraft facts wenn ihr das
geräusch verpasst habt dann seid ihr
blöd wenn ihr es er mitbekommen habt
dann schreibt mir doch jetzt mal die
kommentare was das denn für ein geräusch
gewesen sein könnte ich glaube es war
diesmal schon ein bisschen schwerer als
zuvor letztes mal letzte mal ging es
auch noch relativ klar
aber ja schreibt einfach in die
kommentare von crafter gmail.com
schreiben loaf ex team noch nicht
irgendwo anders waren
und sonst würd ich sagen ich will mich
auf jeden fall sehr sehr darüber freuen
wenn das ganze video bewerten würden
weil es immer eine menge arbeit ist das
ganze zusammen zu schneiden
und jetzt kommt heraus suchen und ganz
perfekt drauf zu suchen